first up he is the host of abc's jimmy
kimmel live can you guess who it is
jimmy kimmel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone thank you i should have
brought that hand that
that you have that's a funny thing is it
a funny thing that we're not allowed to
shake hands because before i come here
they say don't worry
everyone has been tested everything is
perfect there's nothing to worry about
at all
and the athletes shake not only shake
hands they practically kiss each other i
mean
speaking of athletes i pull into your
parking lot
i pull into my spot it says jay kimmel
on it right next to me it says d
strawberry and i'm very excited
very excited because daryl straw it's
not dave's strawberry daryl strawberry
is here
yeah that was a fake name we were trying
to use so people wouldn't know it was me
yeah yeah you are sorry thanks for that
jimmy uh but like an idiot
i'm sitting in the dressing room going
boy nobody's mentioned daryl strawberry
and i thought
oh it's bill is daryl strawberry so
well that's when i was a part owner of
the mets yeah yeah well yeah but you did
well with that right
i eventually did you get the check i did
thank god but first i was writing checks
for this whole last year i was [ __ ]
in my pants like i've never [ __ ] in my
pants you had to write
checks yes you're in for a penny for
apparently i was one of the minority
owners there was
capital calls when they're losing money
and we didn't play baseball for a
hundred games
and then when we did we weren't selling
hot dogs all i was doing was writing
this is my problem we should not really
be talking about this
anyway thank god can i tell you though
you your advice when you told me about
this situation with the mets
i was offered a piece of the las vegas
hobby hockey team the golden knights
the nhl team and they said we'd like to
sell you one percent of the team it's a
great honor and i said
i thought about bill and i thought uh he
didn't seem
that enthused about owning the mets and
i passed i
i did i did until the pandemic came
along
and then by the way i still made out
like a [ __ ] bandit yeah even with all
that i was right
it's the best investment not the [ __ ]
vegas hockey team
but they went to the stanley cup in
their first league [ __ ]
it's hockey it's not even america but
but baseball the new york mets
the national league franchise in new
york city i knew that could not lose
money and it didn't
why didn't they ask you to stay with the
ownership group
well there was first of all after
the near-death experience of pandemic 20
when i was writing those checks
i didn't want to and then that wasn't
i'd who gives a [ __ ] i don't know
i'm out it was a great 10 years at a
parking spot at citi field
i went to see any game i wanted to that
we got into the world series did your
parking spot at city field say d
strawberry on it
maybe but that would have been confusing
because he probably hasn't
exactly yeah so speaking of sports what
about the super bowl
you know what is that this weekend
if i have to listen to any more
sportscasters to all people on tv
sucking tom brady's dick for then
right i get it he's the greatest the
goat
whatever i it's just like please mahomes
beat this [ __ ]
please i i'm so tired of
listening to how great tom brady is
i i am i you know listen mahomes
seems like a nice guy tom brady has
certainly won his share of
everything but um i am rooting for him
because
i think and i think this maybe is true
for a lot of these sportscasters
is this is a guy who was told by his
employer by the way this reminds me a
little bit of you and i'll
explain why stay with me here when you
were at abc they said all right that's
it
we're we're done you went on to become
tremendously successful here at hbo
right like the tom brady and what well
jimmy i think you want the acolytes
but i think everybody everybody has been
fired from a job goes i love to see this
guy
leave his job they go in the toilet he
goes to tampa which is also a toilet
let's be honest uh i lived there i know
and and then he's you know in the super
bowl again who knows he might win it
but i was going to ask you you grew up
in vegas i grew up in las vegas you know
one thing i'm the thing i missed the
most in 2020 and now
i cancelled a bunch of dates again is
touring you don't really tour like i do
no um but i do go to vegas i have a
comedy club in las vegas right and i
enjoy going
there and i i miss vegas i mean that's
one of the main stops obviously i'm
there six or seven times a year at the
mirage
where i was i hope it resumes again i
missed that
i mean i couldn't live there i love
vegas for the weekend
i don't you know you grew up there i
don't know what was that like what was i
mean how did that
how did that shape you growing up in
vegas well in a weird way i guess
i i you know it's funny people when they
ask you about growing up in las vegas
it's as if you grew up on a pirate ship
or something it's like uh
was it was it scary were you drunk all
the time did you lose an eye
didn't you hear the the clanging of the
of the one
armed bandits when you woke up because
that's my image of vegas i wake up and i
go down to breakfast and all i hear
but that's not really you grew up in a
house i grew up in a house
my dad worked for my dad worked for this
company they did
math and my mom was a hooker it was just
a normal upbringing right
that's just enormous no different than
anyone else
[Music]
vegas is still though it's different you
know people
think we need it we need one place in
america
that will be the bastion of political
incorrectness it really is because drive
in
if there's a billboard you can like uh
drive a tank and fire a machine gun
add a ventriloquist out of it and then
there's another guy on another billboard
holding up a lobster the size of an
eight-year-old
well i'm home yes but i mean
the way the direction the country is
going someplace
has to be a place where we don't have to
conform
and be perfect right audience
thank you people
i love it by the way i get a kick out of
watching you i watch you every week and
um
i've enjoyed because i can relate to the
fact that you're doing your show for
your own staff
and i'm doing my show for my own staff i
did it on
i did your show when it was your staff
and they were a great crowd
they were great for you that's why i'm
thinking
i have an idea it's quite frankly my
stuff is sick
switch steps let's trade let's trade
staffs it would be like swinging but
for shows right you know
i also have another plan and i think
this is a good plan
who is because i'm tired of doing the
show for my staff and they're more tired
than i am of it so who is the group
that has been vaccinated and has nothing
but free time
old people oh people i want to start
bringing
groups of their like tell them the bus
is headed to
laughlin or something put them on they
come we'll have bingo we'll do the whole
thing i'll get a bunch of
old people yeah everybody used to have a
talk show that did that it was called
the merv
griffin
[Laughter]
you